we're asked to identify the numerator
and denominator in the fraction 3 over 4
or 3 for it so let's rewrite this just
so it's nice and big so let me just
write the fraction so we have 3 over 3
over 4 3 over 4 now they want to start
to define the numerator and the
denominator the numerator so the
numerator is just the number on top so
the numerator is the 3 right there and
then they want us to find the
denominator the denominator is just the
number on the bottom it's the 4 so if
they say what's the numerator 3 what's
the denominator it's 4 just a number on
the bottom they could have just call
this the number on the bottom they could
have just called this the number on top
now to think about what this represents
what this fraction represents you can
think of 8 of 3 out of 4 pieces of a pie
that's how I think about it so you can
imagine the denominator tells us what
are we taking a fraction out of or how
many pieces are there so let's imagine a
pie like this so we could draw it like
what we could draw it is a square pie so
we could draw it as a square pie so this
is what the denominator represents this
is what the number on the bottom
represents and then 3 says we are
representing three of those four pieces
so this 3 tells us that out of four
possible ones I guess you could think of
it we are using 3 or maybe we're eating
3 so you can imagine someone says I ate
3/4 of a pie this would be read as 3/4
they're eating the blue portion of the
pie if we cut it this way if we you
imagine a round pie it would look like
this let me draw a round pie so that is
my round pie let me cut it into four
equal pieces or roughly equal pieces and
if someone says I ate 3/4 of this pie
where the 3 is the numerator and then
the 4 and you'd read that it's 3/4 the 4
is the denominator they would eat this
much of the pie they would eat 3 of the
4 pieces they would eat 3 of the 4 so
this is one
peace this is two pieces and this is
three pieces so you could imagine the
for the denominator represents the total
number of pieces in the pie and then the
three represents how many of those we
ate